okay hi everyone what I'm about to talk
about it might sound like a
get-rich-quick scheme but um I can
assure you it's all quite legal I get
rich I mean earn enough to at least
replace your salary so um how did I get
into this I mean I've been programming
full for quite a long time starting on
the Apple 2e computer with basic and
Pascal and machine language and then
when PCs came out I co-founded a venture
to write software to sell to doctors in
this fine programming language that was
when having colored our screens was was
all the thing and that business was it
was supposed to create passive income
but it it actually created a lot of
active very active income and then I
moved to London and programmed and when
c-sharp came out I got into that and
then I started got to to write books on
on c-sharp and a rally a written a
number of books and then around 10 years
ago I wrote a software utility called
link pad and it started out as a as a
free utility and this is the what it
looks like it's essentially it's a
scratch it started out as a way to write
link queries interactively against it
outer base but then he turned into a
general purpose code scratch pad and so
when I released that that was ten years
ago in 2007 I released it as a three
months to write I wrote that as a free
free utility and a year later that had
got 50,000 downloads
I'd spent a little bit of time with with
promotion and marketing so it had done
reasonably well and so then I thought
well maybe I couldn't monetize this so I
I wrote a premium edition which was free
and charged extra for that
and that was that that was a few months
later and since then it's been a steady
stream of customers to today and that
totaling the total of 2 million
downloads and a steady stream of paying
Custer
so this I've not employed any one of
it's more than replaced my my full-time
salary that I used to have so I quit
that job and it's also a lot of the time
it's less than than full-time hours so
this kind of business it used to be
called a micro is V but now there's a
new term emerging it's called a software
lifestyle business and and this is a
quite a good term because it it
distinguishes really what's different
about the other kind of business which
is very popular called a startup so so
software lifestyle businesses
prioritizes lifestyle over growths so
you get to do what you enjoy doing with
flexible hours no interference from a
boss'll investors and it doesn't have to
take over your life another key feature
of this is it sustainable in that you
can keep doing this long term and it's
enjoyable so it's not something that you
you do and you put up with and you burn
out and then you retire on the savings
it's something that you can keep doing
year after year and enjoy it
so you're avoiding high-stress long
hours and unpleasant workloads so I've
put together a table tour to really
highlight the difference between
lifestyle startups so like you know
lifestyle is about job satisfaction
startups about growth lifestyle business
low risk moderate return startup high
risk high return you probably know the
statistics on startups that the more
than nine in ten file you know more than
that
lifestyle businesses low capital usually
you can do on your own with minimal
money and rest as startups rely almost
always need to rely on on seed angel
venture capital to work and these
investors will drive you into making
high-risk decisions because they don't
want their money back they want their
money back x hundred or a thousand they
didn't care that what they are going to
try and get you to do has a very high
chance of failing they don't care if
there's a non intention to fail say they
want to make it big and they the reason
they can they could do well out of this
is that they fund numerous they startups
and they all I need is one or two of
them to succeed and they do well
lifestyle business as well you're
looking for small markets and you want
to mostly avoid competition or startups
big markets and you embrace competition
gain lifestyle we have a linear or cap
growth remember we saw that that some
that chart that linear line which is
essentially shows fairly static income
that's exact art lifestyle territory
startup is characterized being
exponential we can also do it on your
own where as a start-up you need at
least two people right unit for a couple
of reasons one is that the business
aspect of it the marketing is incredibly
important and you really need someone to
focus on that full-time but the other is
that if you're looking again to get
capital and there's no way investors are
not going to talk to you and this is at
least two people and this also leads to
the next point where for starter if
you've got a good product with excellent
marketing and business development
that's where you want to be
whereas lifestyle you can do it the
other way around you can have a
excellent product with good marketing
and still succeed and again lifestyle
you enjoy the process will start up you
burn out now this is whose food of Y
Combinator right Y Combinator's a
organizations co-founded by someone
called Paul Graham who was it was
instrumental in the development of Lisp
and they fund they provide seed capital
for startups now this is a quote from
from Paul Graham right small obscure
niche this exists exactly where you want
to be with a lifestyle company as long
as it's not Osos to smaller right where
there's not even enough for an income
now I don't want to knock startups
because I want to highlight the
difference because if you want to do
startups go for it the warning though is
to be very wary the decisions you're
making and that they're consistent with
where you want to go so if you want a
lifestyle business and you don't want to
be except in venture capital
now the prerequisites for setting up a
business like this one is having strong
technical skills being above average
developer that's really going to come in
handy because there's no one else to
carry it you also want to have a broad
skill set which means not just being a
database guy or a or a UI guy you want
you want to do the whole stack and and
also have experienced a lot of different
roles and different company sizes if you
work for a really small company you're
going to be exposed to a lot of the
business and marketing aspects that you
wouldn't if you're isolated in a small
role within a bigger company cultivate
an interest in marketing try and find it
interesting and associate with other
people in entrepreneurial roles probably
the single hardest thing is coming up
with an idea my trying to brainstorm and
think okay what do I write that is one
of the hardest thing is ideas and even
people that have had success in the past
good things when they come up with new
ideas they don't always work but there's
a rule when it comes to ideas good ideas
come when you least want them so you're
trying to get something else done and
something gets in your way that's what
when the good ideas come so you need to
cultivate a state in line where you're
receptive to those make a note somehow
recall these ideas when they come to you
when you're trying to get something else
done keep a constant watch for the fall
for pain points the idea is you want to
come up with an idea that solves a
genuine problem not an imagined problem
unfilled niches are grateful lifestyle
businesses
beware of good but unmarketable ideas
you always think how would you sell that
and if you also hint to other people
you're interested in starting a business
they may come to you with ideas right
and now these are the kind of visit it's
a non-exhaustive list of the business
models for making money from software
now the ones in green are quite good for
lifestyle it's a freemium is great one
you have a free product and website or
some total utility and that then is
useful enough that that sort of spreads
semi virally so if people dispose by
word of mouth and then you that takes
the load off the pressure off
of advertising and then you have you
have a later down the line you introduce
a paid version that people pay extra to
use unlock premium features now that's
another model is subscription you pay a
monthly fee to use something and the two
can work together so if this if you're
developing a website then it can be a
free website with a optional
subscription on there that works well
now if you if you've come up with a
great idea for a library or a framework
for selling for for developers for
programming sometimes the problem is the
only way that's going to be successful
is if you make it open source the
question is how do you make money out of
open source and that can be quite
challenging and sometimes there's
options for writing tools that use work
with your open source librarian you can
make money through that but another one
is that if you're very good at us
promoting your name with that library
right then you you can build a personal
brand and you can leave ridging that all
sorts of ways to make money if nothing
else just consulting it above market
rates right and then good leverage
effect so you probably know the guy for
instance who wrote the most popular json
library right so that's that's good good
marketing and then you know I remember
the guy who wrote him the original
dotnet reflector so that's one way to
make money from through through open
source now the ones in grey the
marketplace is another another option
for you you have a website you put
buyers and sellers together and then you
take a cut and this can work quite well
but it's it is harder to get traction
because you need to get this
chicken-and-egg problem where you've got
buyers and sellers the buyers won't come
without the sell as the sellers won't
come without the bias there's ways
around this but it is it is it is a
little harder to to to get going in
particularly if there are already
competitors in that space is really
really hard when they've already got the
buyers and sellers to get in there sits
a bit more towards the startup territory
and similarly smartphone apps there are
ways to make money through that but most
smartphone apps tend not to put
advertiser funded websites that's even
more the case so to make money from that
it's it's much more likely you're
looking at
startup to make money from that donation
models rarely work I mean it rarely do
you do you make more money using
donation than you would through through
another monetization model now another
thing you need to think about is where
your business is going to sit on the
active versus passive income scale now
obviously you'd all like and ideally you
want to get it as passive as possible
because then you get an income without
having to do so much work or any work
but the harder that the further you go
towards the passive end the harder it is
I believe to get a successful business
so it's easy it's more realistic to get
somewhere thing that's sort of in the
middle in that scale so that means there
is going to be ongoing active work
whether that's releasing updates are
doing support so what you need to ask
yourself is what is the nature of that
ongoing active work and is that
something you enjoy and is that
something that's consistent with the
lifestyle you want now this is probably
one of the most important things step
one is to write a business plan once
you've got your idea you don't need a
business plan so an example when you
don't need a business plan is if if you
write something purely for the fun of it
and then that and that then that morphs
into a business great but if you are
incurring costs or making any sacrifices
with the hope of future rewards you need
a business plan now you might say well
I've got one in my head right but
there's three problems with that one is
it will lack detail second it will be
laced with cognitive biases that won't
become obvious until they're on paper
and the third is that over time the
business plan will evolve now if it's in
your head you lose the history so you
can't learn from your mistakes
so you start with when you're writing a
business plan you the thing is start
with this market research and I would
say from what I've read I've I've
researched in the way these small
software businesses fail the most common
reported calls is poor market research
this is absolutely essential you need to
identify the market does it even exist
right how big is the market how are you
reached them and is there an obvious
need for your product how are you people
to know that it's
obvious and that these are the
challenges you could have identified the
challenges to selling this is a I'm
surprised how many people don't do this
have you ever heard you know you gone to
a party and then someone I'll see what
you do and you say I'm a programmer and
they say I've got a great idea for a
smartphone app have you ever had that
and then they want you to write it and
sell it and market it and they want half
the income they they came up with the
idea that's fair enough and then you ask
them you know is it have you done have
you got a business plan have you done
competitive analysis I do a quick search
on google for three seconds so then I
spent all of 30 seconds doing a search
on Google and it's there's people
already doing this now this is this
happens it's also a cognitive bias it's
that they think their idea is so
original no one else can possibly have
thought of it right but I'll tell you
there is no such thing as an original
idea it's almost certainly somebody's
thought of it right whether or not they
brought something to market that's good
as something else but it's essentially
there's there's also a more subtle form
of confirmation bias so when you're
looking at your competitors products you
look at them through dark colored
glasses and you look at your potential
product through rose-colored glasses
it's worth reading up on confirmation
bias and you need to take that into
account to make sure that you get a very
impartial view of the market in general
for lifestyle businesses you want to
avoid too much competition because it
increases the risk now sometimes it's
okay to go ahead of their competitors
sometimes the products failed and if
some product is fired you've got to be
honest about why it's fail what it's
easy to be simplistic and say well they
were just stupid they probably weren't
stupid they Charlie try quite hard to
make it work so you need to be careful
about that one sometimes that product is
abandoned and one of the reasons but
abandoned is if let's say it's been
bought out by another company and then
they lose interest in it and they stop
developing it sometimes what happens is
they'll start out as lifestyle and then
they'll move into startup territory so
they might be setting up a website
subscription they charge but they've a
free version and they
up to $50 a month for that for that
produced for using their free premium
features and then they decide later
we're going to only women start charging
$500 a month
they're now fine there's a lucrative
enterprise market is paying it so
they've abandoned that lifestyle market
leaving it open for someone else
another reason is you may have an
immutable advantage so if your
competitor is locked into an old
platform and it's very expensive for
them to rewrite in the new platform
that's a good reason
beware of going into business simply
because your product will have one
killer feature that there one doesn't
have because think about how hard would
it be for them to add that killer
feature because you know I've seen this
happen you know people have seen they've
got this advantage it disappears
overnight also a final point is rapidly
expanding markets and changing markets
are friendly to new players whereas
static and shrinking markets favor
incumbents now if your competitor is a
big company that by itself doesn't mean
you can't compete because big companies
have got big resources but they've got a
lot of big overheads too it's a lot of
you work for big companies and you know
about all the stuff that goes on there
big companies a creative ways finding
ways to be inefficient right you want
one thing you do need to watch out for
is they do have big companies which they
have big capital so if they see you as a
significant threat they can kind of
crush you by temporarily lowering their
price below your cost
now then its essence second step is to
find a business partner if you need one
you don't necessarily need a business
partner the reasons you may want to have
a business partner is if you're getting
into a market into which you're not
intimately familiar or a market in which
you lack connections now just because
someone came up with the idea that
doesn't compel you to go into business
with them you want to go into business
with someone who's providing an ongoing
complimentary contribution and who's
competent in that role and that you can
get on well with they don't necessarily
have to be an equal partner
you might cut them in on a share of
sales or or some other mechanism now
there's three kinds of business partner
one is a business person which is this
kind of person is good if you're selling
into a difficult market like big
companies of government and that person
has connections and experience but if
you're going to use someone like that
make sure they're wealthier than you
otherwise it's kind of like employing a
programmer that's never written a
program that works the second kind of
person is a salesperson and that is that
applies to products that need somebody
on the road selling it and this is often
the case of vertical market you need
someone like that and this is probably
less lifestyle the more active income
but these people that are easy to pay
you pay them on Commission that's
normally what they want anyway you boot
and the Third Kind is a domain expert
now these are amongst Simone it is
important because they can get you into
places you will neither wise go
because without domain expertise you you
really can't write a program you can't
sell into the widget market unless you
understand widgets now I think the most
important thing was domain experts is to
use more than one because you'll almost
certainly get a biased view of the
industry if you rely on one domain
expert get multiple domain experts and
they don't necessarily have to be a
happy part of your business but one
reason you might want to involve a
domain expert in your business as a
partner is if they have connections in
the industry those can be extremely
useful they can make or break so an
example let's say you're you're going to
come up with a business a marketplace a
marketplace where actors can be audition
for casting roles so you're going to get
the actors together with the with the
roles and they're going to cast online
and that's the marketplace and you're
going to take a maybe 10% of the of the
commission now if you want to set
something like that up then who who
would be better to partner with an actor
or a casting director that has hundreds
of actors on her book and is well
connects
in the industry with movie studios
someone who sits on committees right
that decision could easily make or break
and it's way way way more important than
than whether you decide to use react or
angular to write your website
another point is the personality and
this is when you've got two people as
you can't vote to resolve a difference
so every disagreement is a potential
deadlock you need to be able to freely
discuss ideas and come to agreements and
the biggest barrier to that is egos
people that have got my idea versus your
idea and this is this is a killer and
this what I mean in the in the end it
can it can drive you to insanity if
you're forced to works with someone
where you can't just put your egos aside
and discuss the pros or cons of an idea
something else to be aware of is you
will need to draw up an agreement
between you in advance and also think
about how each person contributes it
might be more one to capital one more
time and some person one person's role
that they may work for three months and
there's nothing else for them to do and
now the other person's got to work for
much longer so you could figure out how
you sort these things out because a
failure here can cause a lot of
resentment later on and very importantly
you need to both agree on whether it's
lifestyle will start up as well that's a
good book for negotiating it talks about
interest based negotiation rather than
positional negotiation now step three is
to marketing you want to really start
this before you start writing the
product right that has a number of
advantages one is if you get stuck and
you can't figure out how to do the
marketing you saved yourself the hassle
riding the product all right it's
unmarketable you also if you start
establishing relationships early start
getting the marketing done early you're
getting us you're giving yourself a big
head start getting involved into the
community into which you're selling that
is probably an extremely valuable
to do that because it's early you get
knowledge and you get connections find
out who the influential people are if
you're for instance selling to
developers like MVPs people that hang
out in Stack Overflow so on those are
the people you need and you can
establish business relationships and to
do that think about other businesses
that you can help what can you do what
can your business see that will help
other businesses and then think what
they can they do back for you right then
you contact them and you've got some
some traction a recommendation from
someone who's influential in the in the
community is is way more powerful than
advertising because it's somebody else
that they trust saying your products
good rather than you saying your product
is good now what's the magic four-letter
word it's free all right that's that's a
good way from anything that's free
people tend to like so you can do quite
well without having to spend a lot on
advertising free models that make money
lost leader is where you have one free
product which acts as an advert for
something else
freemium is kind of like lost leader but
the product acts as an advert for itself
grandfathering can work with them
subscription sites so that you can set
up the first thousand people a free
membership forever no fees right so they
get grandfathered onto a plan and that
helps you get your initial user base up
and also they can act as ambassadors
later on is it always going to be
happier your other customers cuz they're
getting it for free going give them free
products to influential people be really
wary about exactly what you give away in
how you give stuff away because the
customers hate it if you take stuff back
right but it's effectively kind of bait
and switch and you probably remember
some years ago with dotnet reflector
which used to be free and then it became
a paid product and the way in which that
happened earlier nated a lot of
customers now with advertising one
biggest of one word of advice is to
experiment because nowadays you can use
the platforms that they have automated
portals where you can upload creatives
you can run them and you can measure and
compare the results so try lots of
different small-scale tests change one
thing at a time and look
to see whether there's a difference
modes and sights could saturate so you
might do really well with a campaign and
then you try it again you don't do so
well because effectively you've picked
the low-hanging fruit right there's a
limited number of people that will
easily buy your product and you've
already they've already bought it he's
like I ran I ran ads on stackoverflow
that was probably their most successful
I ran I'd also tried Google with a lot
less success I had Facebook with some
success Facebook I got quite a lot of of
clicks but not so many sales Stack
Overflow actually generated sales but I
was amazed at the differences between
changing stuff in the creatives and the
the difference between those ads it's
not particularly important because it's
probably going to be different for your
product but the important thing is I
only ran those I ran them very quickly
and then I got those those results soon
so that way I avoided wasting time on
the ones that weren't working now
another way to get your product out
there is to get resellers to do it for
you and it's that there's a bit of a
trap here because there's two kinds of
resellers there's active resellers do
that they get your product and find
customers and then there are passive
resellers where a customer will count
will already know about your product and
then they'll say can I find a reseller
to get this cheaper or more commonly
what they'll do is they're not after
it's so much a discount but a lot of
corporate customers have got very
bureaucratic purchasing processes and so
they work better through resellers so
they use the reseller just to you know
because they fake them to send them a
check or something like that so you've
got to make sure that your strategy for
resellers differentiates between the two
don't waste money giving away discounts
to passive resellers you don't have to
give them any discount give them a very
very small token one but find out is
your product conducive to actively
selling and if so try and find those
those resellers so okay well how far now
is it about halfway through and we've
haven't even started writing it yet okay
so this is all the preparation so now it
comes to writing the product what do you
need to write to code up it's pretty
cheap you need a computer
thousand bucks unless you're a Apple fan
which case is going to be 2,000 or 3,000
you want to get your favorite editors
free source control free and the most
important thing of all is a link pad
premium license because without that I
can guarantee you won't succeed
now who's heard of the single
responsibility principle right this is a
different kind of single responsibility
right be first to market with a minimum
feature set that defines your product
this is really important
try to aim to get your v1 out there
within a few months it doesn't have to
be perfect it just has to be good enough
to captures people people's imagination
alright so get rid of everything that
slows you down in doing that now there's
a number of benefits from doing this one
is that your product might fail right or
it might be that you need to change
direction it would you rather change
direction in three months time or in a
year's time this is extremely important
you get that feedback early it also an
other people competitors might already
remember there's no such thing as an
original idea there are probably other
people also working on it right when I
started writing link pad I wrote it in
three months when I went registered the
domain name link pad com was already
taken someone else is working on this
and I reckon I got there first because I
wasn't doing TDD or 235 layer
architecture well I just wrote it and
got it out there it's an interesting
point which is what happens when you get
to that you know three months you
release it and nothing you get
absolutely nothing you've got to think
you know is this something I do I need
to go back and do more work on marketing
do I need to pivot the product what do I
do and you may want to spend some more
time on it before you give up but be
really aware of the sunk cost fallacy
and this is another cognitive bias where
you know you think I've spent a year on
this now that will be I can't give that
up in a year on it so I'm going to keep
going you know so you could ignore what
you've spent on it just think about the
future when you're making those
decisions now
when you when you're programming you you
want a big kill at this point is over
engineering so you really want to avoid
over engineering
and but similarly you want to avoid
under engineering so this graph kind of
shows the effect of both that but over
engineering you know you're obviously
putting up the development cost under
engineering means that you're you're
giving way to impatience and you'll
start coding before you've properly
thought it through right we've all done
this at some point right ends up being
much more expensive it takes a lot of
discipline and maturity to stay in the
middle of that graph so you could say on
one side on the under engineering side
you've got spaghetti code UAS what you
end up with and on the over engineering
side you end up with lasagna code we've
got hundreds of layers and there's a
tiny little bit of meat between each
layer he's an example so working
efficiently for yourself you need to
abandon that big company mentality avoid
those bloated methodology methodologies
and rituals
be wary of hype so any technology like
it no sequel or service we've got to do
service and no sequel it's scalable do
you need to be scalable probably not
right so use whatever gives you the best
bang for the buck today good old
databases are probably what you're going
to be using best practices treat them as
guidelines right not rules pragmatism
you want to be absolutely relentlessly
pragmatic on there he's an example
automated testing now it's fair to say
that the bigger the team the more
important it is to have techno tomato
tests so what does that say about team
size of one right they're less important
you should be spending less time with
your automated testing now of course
they're exceptions to this but I'm
talking about a general fair
generalization now of all the kinds of
automated tests you can have unit tests
are the most inefficient they're
voluminous to write whenever you
refactor your code you've got a refactor
or rewrite your unit tests it's they're
expensive to maintain they're also they
introduce additional complexity into
your code things such as IRC containers
they're the first things that you want
to go easy on a unit tests you get much
better value out of tests operated a
higher
module layer testing integration tests
work much better one of the best tests
you get is regression testing so
regression testing is when you take a
newer version of your software you're
about to release you run some data
through it then you measure the output
you record it to a file it could be an
HTML or a log file and you do the same
with the older version of the software
and then you compare the two to see if
there's differences I do this with link
pad has built in new great integration
so you can reference new get libraries
so every now and then I need to upgrade
the new get client to support all the
packages and the problem is there's a
very high chance that some libraries are
going to break when that happens so what
I do is I've got a regression test so it
automatically downloads the 500 most
popular new get packages and it runs all
of them through the newer version of
link pad and then through the older
version of link pattern and then it
records any differences now that was
about that much code took about half a
day or nothing a few hours to write that
code and that does so much it captures
so many things with such little effort
what about source control do you even
need source control well I'll tell you a
story my brother he's he'd been working
on a start-up and he was over last
Christmas and he was with his laptop and
he had his project open he left his
laptop unlocked on the couch and this
guy jumped up onto the couch and made a
few edits right he fat pulled the
keyboard and then Ben didn't realize
that anything had happened because the
editor was open on a configuration file
so the next time he he deployed it to
the cloud it didn't work and the error
messages were misleading and unhelpful
he spent hours figuring out that it was
due to Wobby spores the the error so
this can't happen if you got source
control your work in progress is staring
you in the face right that's the one
reason alone that is to have it but
there's many other benefits one is
having an easily accessible history if
you're working on your own
you don't get the luxury of somebody
else to review your code you've got to
do your own code reviews so how do you
do that so what you do is you you review
your commits in your source control and
you change hats so you take off your
cool new feature hat and you put on that
what could possibly go wrong hat what's
this going to break and then you look at
you and you look at your commits from
that other point of view that's also an
excellent time to sync have I remember
to comment those the bits of the source
code that need commenting right that's
when you pick it up so you'll get that
with source control it also a good
source control that means get encourages
experimentation by making it really easy
to create branches and when you create
branches you can do all sorts of
interesting experiments without having
to commit to them you can just leave
them there
you can switch effortlessly switch to
another branch go back to your old
branch create another one and then you
can um later on if you want you can
effortlessly merge and cherry-pick
between the branches so effectively this
decouples
feature i'm development from future
deployment you can release updates while
writing new features and you'll of
course get free of free backup as well
as your other mechanisms that you use
for backup
now the reason I'm suggesting I mean
probably most of you I think all of you
will probably be using it right but and
his branching support is killer and it's
just as useful with solo development I
use that a lot that's the payback you
get from all the complexity and get big
bucket is free hosting it doesn't have
to be open source and it's still free if
you if you are not a guru would get and
you want to use a GUI
and they didn't used to be any good
gooeys in my opinion but recently get
Kraken has been released and I think
that's I really like it's what it looks
like and it's it does make it a lot
easier it's the only GUI actually really
enjoy using and it really means you
don't really have to worry about the
arcane command-line syntax and get but I
will give you one bit of warning if
you're using it and we know what role or
capacity there's a huge track with git
which is that
is to cargo cult your way through it
because the underlying model is is a
little bit more complex than you'd
imagine and it's really really clever
and beautiful the underlying modeling
kit but if you don't understand it
you're anywhere for a world of suffering
right so my recommendation is really
spend a half a day or whatever learning
the underlying model right said that you
know that a branch for instance it's
nothing more than a pointer and a commit
does not reference a change set it
references a tree if you know the
difference between a log and a ref log
and a rebase in a merge if you don't
know these things it's just how but if
you know them it's mostly pretty good
especially but it good going so
designing your software whether it's a
website or utility keep the UI simple
and clean really simple really clean and
focus the UI around your main use cases
if someone goes to your website or
downloads your software that taking a
judge it within seconds they're going to
be forming opinions make sure it's
really obvious how to do what your site
or your products exists before now for
if you're deploying a rich client app
make sure it it updates itself right
from the beginning because you're if
you're releasing a free version you're
later gonna wanna probably release a
freemium version right so people won't
know it exists if it doesn't
automatically update this is what you
get when you download a rich client for
Windows right when you download utility
that's the first thing that your
customer sees when they click the
download now if they get this fur
they're probably you've probably built
enough trust that then they will be
assuming that there are no viruses here
so we'll assume that there isn't it a
trust issue with regarding viruses but
nonetheless how many of you are
reluctant to run that even if you know
there's no virus right there's all sorts
of stuff that can do to your machine
right all sorts of unpleasant deposits
I've had the cat picture so now it's
time for the dog picture but there's a
way around this particularly in the
earlier days when you're establishing
reputation which is to offer standalone
executable which is something that's
xcopy deployable
so that way they can run it if they
don't like it they can delete it right
also bypasses that nasty setup screen
that a lot of programs have when it asks
you way too many questions and tries to
install bloatware at the same time you
know automatically checked so we're not
in the early days of link pad I I tried
I offered both I still do but it was
there was a big favor like though to to
wander the Downloads to old Sandler and
executables so people do like that
so now you've written it maybe you've
got your free version released and now
you want to release our free premium
edition so these are the issues with
monetization even deal with software if
you're buying a programming that you
norm used to be a perpetual license so
you buy version one and that entitles
you to use it forever
and you'll get free updates for a year
or so and then if you want up great a
vision to later on you're paying upgrade
fee that's a standard perpetual license
that that's been the norm and it's still
a good way to go if your product is
going to be used intermittently or
occasionally that that is probably the
best model but nowadays
subscription-based licensing is becoming
far more common and I believe it's a
better way to monetize your product it's
even for software for standard downloads
so paying a monthly or a yearly fee and
automatically renews it is it a better
way to monetize it and it means that if
they stopped paying the next stop using
the software now one thing I would not
use this for as a gain is software that
people use occasionally so if they're
using in their day-to-day workflow
they're willing to be having a
subscription for what I believe but if
it's something that you use from time to
time I would certainly would resist a
subscription-based model subscription
also works well with with websites
obviously the hybrid models is where you
you pay for the license and then you
optionally can also buy support and
updates and it automatically renews
every year for a small or a fee and it
keeps you a regular regular with updates
that's a good compromise
yeah the industry's becoming more
accepting of subscription-based but you
want to start with perpetual and then
convert to subscription because again
you're taking something away people hate
it when you take something away like the
right to use that software forever with
websites again you'll be using
subscription or marketplace now when
you're processing payments if you're
selling internationally you're not going
to be selling in Australian dollars
right going to be selling in US dollars
later on you cared more currencies as
well and that restricts you if you go to
your local Australian bank and then you
want an credit card merchant account but
lets you bill in this dollars it's
either difficult or impossible so the
options stripe PayPal Braintree will
paying I've the ieave you stripe and
PayPal stripe I believe is very good
I've had no trouble at all in the last
couple of years it's quite a modern
slick user interface as stripe as you as
your product matures you want to
integrate two different payment gateways
in case one goes bad all right because
otherwise you can lose a lot of sales if
you go off flying it can take you a week
to get all the integration in terms of
not just a technical side but signing
all the agreements and everything so you
don't want to be offline for a week so
if it becomes earning more income
integrate two of them I do stripe and
PayPal right another possible pair could
be Braintree and PayPal but I would
caution against that because Braintree
is owned by PayPal so if you've got a
business dispute with them you could
lose both of them now marketplaces if
you're doing a marketplace you're taking
a cut from transactions that requires
special features you have to be wary of
that which ones you choose now I'm
stringing contact with customers you
make sure that when you they buy your
product or that they you have an opt-in
checkbox that you can email them again
because without that you're basically
spamming them now what I found is that
one and two will check the box so that
means you need other ways you can stay
in contact with them and a lot of people
will like using Twitter on Facebook so
make sure those details are in your
initial email because you get one chance
to email them like the the messages sent
here is your license thank you for your
purchase you can do that whether the
check the opt-in or not so that's
one chance to make sure you put
everything in there you can also contact
customer through your app itself so when
they use your website or the app it can
pop something up so final step is
running the business big role is to
automate everything you can possibly
automate all purchasing licensing
operations we sell our quotes uploading
builds and so on now there's two reasons
you want to automate things one of them
is that over the long term you're
probably save time but the other is that
and remember this is a lifestyle
business so it's really important that
you know it's enjoyable now doing this
kind of day-to-day mundane this stuff is
not enjoyable writing code to automate
it
that's coding that's fun right that's
enjoyable so you're making you your job
better at the same time this is an
interesting problem at the beginning
you've got to make a decision as to what
features to work on and you can really
put features into two categories now at
the beginning when you're trying to get
your marquee enough for first three
months you're getting your v1 out you
want that slider right over to the left
right so you're what your what your
features the most important features but
once your product becomes more
established and if it's a lifestyle
business you can start sliding that a
bit over to the right right if it's a
startup you keep that far over to the
left until you die we'll have your
nervous breakdown now the reason that
you want that that that slider over to
the to the right is that imagine that
you're okay you're running a consultancy
company and you're hiring programmers
and you're taking work on you've got
really really crack team of programmers
and this client comes to you offering
you really big money to do this vb6
maintenance job are you gonna give that
to you
tsa the next year your top program is
you're going to be doing this vb6
maintenance what's gonna happen they're
gonna leave you wouldn't do that even
though it's there's a good business case
for it prima-facie you're going to lose
your biggest asset now if you're running
a livestock business you are the only
employee would you do that to yourself
would you give yourself too many shitty
features to work on right because
eventually you'll get rid of that
business if it's too unpleasant you'll
end up getting a job so you've got to
run a
see it and find abouts of things that
that are enjoyable to work on things
that benefit your product now that also
brings up the question of how do you
know what are the features that your
product needs you need to make easy for
users to give feedback they shouldn't
have to sign into anything to do it so
give away that particularly at the
beginning is when it's most important to
get feedback so if it's a rich client
you've got on the help menu give
feedback and if it's a website again
make it really easy for people to give
suggestions and feedback and then you
can contact them because some of the
people at the beginning that give a lot
of feedback very early adopters and they
become like ambassadors for your product
so establish a relationship with them
you've got to know when to say no
because it's easy a lot of features that
may seem like a good idea but they come
a hidden cost like they make the the
product look scattered or unfocused it's
not obvious what it's supposed to do or
how it works
avoid things that clutter that the UI or
create unintuitive subtle use cases
extremely careful that what you leave
out is is important is what you put in
now there's a website which I use called
user voice calm where people can then
vote on their features publicly and then
you can vote them up user voice still
come I've been using that for years and
it works really well particularly at the
beginning where you really have no idea
and so the most popular ones bubble up
to the top now that's that site used to
be it was something possibly a lifestyle
business it was they had plans ranging
from free which will I'm on I'm
grandfathered onto that up to $50 a
month but recently that's now that
they've abandoned that market and now
they're charging $500 a month to use
user voice minimum they're going for the
big corporate customers so that means
there's a market now a niche for a
lifestyle business that does what they
used to do so what's the first thing we
do we've come up with the idea what do
we do next
competitive analysis very good so let's
have a search I did this I did a search
as to what was else is available and two
months ago somebody released this
feature upvote it exists exactly to fill
that niche she even said so I contacted
the guy who wrote this the other day and
he lives ezel he does lifestyle
businesses
he lives in Spain and he said he's had
very similar advice to what I've given
in this session he even suggested that
when you're starting a website to
release it before it's it's up to the v1
standard release it when it's like a
point five and don't worry about the
fact that you're not going to get many
visitors
it gives you a chance to work more on
marketing and then alternate between
marketing and improving your site so the
bad news is yes someone else is doing
that but the good news is that's only
$29 a month so if you want to go to get
feedback that's that's how you can do it
so you need to you want to release your
updates regularly particularly early on
because whenever you release won't make
a new feature release it generates some
publicity so whenever you use enough new
features or something exciting for
people to tweet about or tell people
about do it do a release and then and
then promote that promote that so
interim beta builds if we get beta
testers so establish a group of people
who could who they'll happily be test
you your software for free right just so
they can get the new features so here's
a summary i've always keep a lookout for
business ideas write a business plan
don't forget competitive analysis be
careful who you choose for a business
partner and start early with marketing
get to market quickly with your v1 don't
over under engineer automate everything
get feedback update regularly now I've
also done some research on where people
have reported their lifestyle businesses
and the results they've got from them
and these are the the four most common
reasons for failure right poor market
research number one insufficient domain
expertise
right no industry connections and taking
too long to file or pivot so we've got a
few minutes from the more than that
we're about nearly ten minutes so do we
have any questions I'll also be in the
next session I'm in room eight for
questions
yet the back
right sir I can't hear you can you can
you speak up
did you say open open source or a
microphone and make it easier oh that's
great
so you suggested - not to use overhyped
tools that you yes but provided you're
doing this back at the beginning
why not to try them variety spoon a
month time learning node sure influence
something yeah yeah but we're with
overhype things I'm not saying don't use
them but don't use them just because
they're hyped because sometimes the hype
stuff does actually genuinely it is
really good and if it suits what you're
doing so sometimes it exists to solve a
problem and and that is relevant to what
you're doing and again you do make a
good point is if you if it makes it more
enjoyable then that in itself can be a
reason and sometimes business ideas can
come out of one of those hot
technologies because you when something
is hyped there's a lot of stuff goes on
around it and that can open up new
markets new ideas so that there's a
there's a whole thing around hyped
technologies that can create niches for
products yes there are some marketing
steps you can do in advance of writing
it so I'm getting involved into the
industry into which you're selling so
I'm getting to know the people and
establish business connections getting
to know the industry those are the
things you can do first and also the
plan your you can write your plan and
work out what you're going to do first
so everything that you can possibly do
before you write it you do that in
advance including the planning
yes he writes some software that destroy
someone's life and they want to see you
or something what sort of legal
framework do you recommend to sit on
first okay so I mean someone can't sue
you because it destroys their business
but that you can get sued for other
other reasons now
I'm really only a non-lawyer side I'm
not going to give any advice on the
legal aspect of it oh it's probably
better to get advice I mean one of the
things that will protect you to some
extent is that you're a pretty small
target so you know they're normally
lawsuits that they're after they're
after big money so and you're not simply
not going to do it if you're an
individual so it's not usually an issue
I haven't heard of being of small over
of small businesses being sued like that
but it's also incredibly damaging it
can't like if a big company comes in and
Susan individual that that's just
disastrous public relations so it's not
usually a problem I don't have you got
any thoughts or experiences around
targeting different types of market so
some of the things that I have in mind
more something that's a niche but
probably targets larger corporates and
then thinking of this kind of
distinction between lifestyle and so
forth I imagine it might be a bit harder
obviously it's a lot harder getting in
the door of corporates but yes you know
a lot more expectations around yeah so
forth yeah I would I would if it was
corporate I would partner up with
somebody yeah I wouldn't do that on my
own you know I'd get someone else who
loves that kind of stuff and and because
you really want to be focusing mostly on
I mean you obviously have to do both
marketing and technical but but for a
lot of us we want to be spending most
our time doing technical stuff so if
it's if the marketing stuff is difficult
with the business development sod then
you I would partner up with someone who
who enjoys doing that how many hours a
week you
and how much of your workers say you
spend on marketing this as I will put at
the beginning its you would probably be
well to be honest it is with this kind
of business it's mostly technical that's
the good thing about it but the at the
beginning there is quite a lot of
marketing you might spend third of your
time on that as the product matures then
it tends to be less because the
technical features and you the more a
product grows the harder it is to write
new features it takes in exponentially
longer to integrate them so you tend to
spend more time on the technical things
and you also tend to often repeat the
same kind of things of marketing so it
becomes it is it I'll say dominantly
it's predominantly its its technical but
marketing is still quite blunt
especially at the beginning yes
okay it's piracy a big problem with
desktop the question it's a very good
question and the answer is it depends on
the particular type of product now with
some products like like tools link pad
for instance is quite pirate a bull now
there's some things that work in your
favor like one is that corporations
generally do not want a pirate software
generally sometimes it's ended more
individuals that want to do it you can
you can easily put in activations based
licensing for tools that it doesn't make
it there's no such thing as bulletproof
in preventing piracy but it makes it
much harder so with relatively little
effort if you're quite clever about how
you can do it you can make it
sufficiently difficult that there will
be eventually cracks for your software
around but that there will be there
won't be very trustworthy they'll be on
some you know dodgy Russian site or
something and people will be worried
about viruses so I found in practice and
the piracy is not really a big issue if
you make a moderate effort with your
activation based licensing but it's also
really important to be here on the side
of generosity so when it comes to how
many activations do you provide and do
you let people transfer licenses online
and so on it's always better to treat
your customers as though they're honest
people so that you generate goodwill yes
you mentioned being weary of trying to
create your business around that one
killer feature that an established
company could come in in one fell swoop
what yes what about doing that in the
hopes of maybe being acquired and
selling the business off and moving on
to something else well there's really I
think those two are independent so that
they hope so if you're setting up a
business and over being acquired it's
that's probably more startup domain than
lifestyle domain it's unlikely that
they'll acquire a startup business
lifestyle business unless they can use
your product in a way that strategic
importance for them so for them they
meant they they could use it in a much
bigger way so that's that's completely
separate to the that the previous point
about having a killer feature that they
don't have I mean I've seen it happen
but it is if there if there is a if
you're going to produce a product is
identical to someone else and you've got
one extra feature that's really good
there's a really good chance that they
you know again you're not the only one
to think about it and that they're
probably working on that as well so
unless there's a reason why they won't
or can't do it I wouldn't say down to
about say very wary of it
do you know anyone who's used patents to
protect their IP in a lifestyle that's
very good question I don't know a lot
about that now when it comes to patents
I understand that the cost of obtaining
a pattern that can be robustly enforced
it's somewhere between I think a few
hundred thousand and a million dollars
so it's I'm not sure how that can really
work in I mean I've heard of people
getting patents and then trying to use
those patents with mixed success I don't
think you're going to be able to enforce
it if without that their legal fees but
again that's not something I know a lot
about okay so we're out of time now so
I'm going to be in a room 8 upstairs if
you want to ask any more questions
thanks everyone
[Applause]